on va se faire un petit débrief de
l'émission d'hier soir de top chef qui a
très très bien démarré la 11ème tome
fait carton il était leader sur les
moins de 50 ans top chef et on va faire
un petit débrief de l'émission d'hier
alors généralement dans l'émission les
candidats ils sont speed il fonce il
déborde d'énergie
mais pas de rire alors y'a un mec qui
s'appelle adrien lui de 21h05 jusqu'à la
fin de l'émission on a vu le mec le plus
détendu et c'est le doc gynéco de la
cuisine regarde
[Musique]
non mais n'a pas compris qu'il fallait
aller vite
je me battrai pour toi je peux pas très
pour toi d'accord et je te ferait gagner
top chef est en jeu
[Musique]
avant épicène jamais autant vu de ma vie
je fais un petit vous avez cru voir
comme ça on avait stéphane rotenberg
ouest très heureux pour lui il s'agit
très bien marcher parce qu'ils le
méritent
j'avais un peu délaissé top chef pour
tout voir dire et je suis retourné un
petit peu à reculons et en fait j'ai été
accrochés notamment parce qu'il ya un
nouveau chef
il ya une nouvelle règle avec maintenant
un candidat solidaire est sûre ça
vachement bien du coup ça m'a samax à
samatan +5 vous dire il ya un problème
aussi c'est que enfin les concurrents
voilà oui sûrement mais là ils réclament
enfin ça fait trois jours de fuite ou
tf1 est à la ramasse total ce sont des
fans l'hitler trois séries si la
catastrophe en soi un magnum de la série
h 24 et l' émergence
là on ne renouvelle série aussi qui
prend pas donc c'est vrai que deux
matchs énormes sans moustache comme
c'est comme je sais pas moi c'est c'est
comme quoi garnir son magnum cij venir
mais mélange donc pas ça si mal
ouais mais parce qu'elle va aller sur
tf1 allez chiche best a tenté de motiver
les candidats autant ils sont chauds
pour gagner par contre y'a pas grand
monde pour être grand monde pour être
dans son équipe il s'est pris un four
thermostat 220 noeuds
vous venez de choses enfants
ouais qui veut gagner top chef quoi ok
donc y venir avec moi j'adore l'émission
médias ça monte tout ça sur les très
très honnête par rapport à la
concurrence de tf1 qui avait avant mais
en vrai savez travers lui à millions
alors que tf1 c'est une cata hier soir
je t'adresse à abc ben non si tu remets
ça la concurrence de l'année dernière ce
que faisait des terrains qui faisait pas
trois millions monter les femmes se sont
ils se sont vite ils sont plutôt aux moi
c'est vrai que la concurrence était très
très faible hier soir même sur les
chaînes de la tnt
c'était une catastrophe même nous on n'a
pas trop bien marché mais hier en prime
time on a fait 600 mines et quelques
téléspectateurs avec en cas de forte
tension vous rappeler de ces
milliardaires avec le lancement réussi
le nouveau chef est bon et puis un an je
sais qu'il ya deux candidats éliminés
pour une première émission souvent vous
présente les gens le seul reproche que
j'ai c'est 01 11 la fin moi je peux rien
dire moi je fais des émissions les plus
longues du monde sur ça je peux pas
critiquer 2h41 jour devant on a
découvert
on a découvert l'histoire touchante d'un
jeune garçon malaurie qui explique un
drame et nous explique comment il a
perdu un oeil
le garçon est très touchant et regardé
par contre c'est vrai qu'il devrait
éviter d'employer certaine déception
mais j'ai craqué pour ce gardien
malheureusement j'ai eu un accident en
à la fin de mon stage dans un restaurant
étoilé aussi on m'a baptisé et puis les
vins sont par terre un collègue ou la
jetée en fait dans le seau il y avait de
l'eau mélangée avec de l'acide que je
les prie dans le visage il depuis ce
jour là voilà j'ai perdu la vue
entièrement d'un côté ça a changé ma vie
j'ai ouvert les yeux sur beaucoup de
choses
alors comme chef qu'après bien marquer
moi c'est vrai que alors johnny et
j'adore stéphane rotenberg
l'émission est très bien fait mais moi
les émissions d'un doublé je m'en tape
mais complet je ne regarde jamais vous
savez que c'est très sexy un type qui
cuisine cuisine elle avale info il a
feint un truc qu'est ce que tu fais pas
tu fais que des trucs mégane ce sont les
vegans on est créatif en a c'est vrai
que ça voudrait dire être encore plus
créatifs
tu fais c'est quoi ta spécialité tu veux
tu viendras la maison sise à un accord
non juste un petit bon moi j'ai comme
vous je dois attendre quatre heures pour
savoir s'ils n'arrivent jamais à 34
savoir s'ils ont fourré la donne ces
brèches et voilà non non j'ai un petit
mot parce que ça formidable
est-ce que c'est depuis cette émission
pas le handicap est très présent la
télévision maintenant ouais c'est très
bien et notamment où tu n'es de grégory
qui bien sûr qu'avec avec un match il a
monté un restaurant à lyon maintenant
mais cartonne totalement et voilà ce
qu'il aurait pu sans ça donc je sais
qu'en ce moment il faillait une balade
est de plus en plus de personnes qui ont
accès à la télévision qui sont
handicapés et notamment ses missions
extrêmement c'est très bien mais c'est
vrai bravo en tout cas c'est pas rien
ici pour m6 à 22h40 si j'ai fait la
connaissance de justin ali dadkhah le
sourire quoi qu'il arrive elle l est
tout autant te regarde assez d'injustice
j'essaie de pas leur montrer que il me
déstabilisait et je souris
j'ai comme une roue je me sens comme une
guerrière en plein sur le ring
magnifique je suis rôti bâlois s'est pas
inintéressant ok ok ça marche parce
qu'un équilibre dit qu il comprenne mon
assiette
ils sont amenés tellement avisé
[Musique]
qui a été éliminé hier
il dément les arthur n'ont pas de chance
mais c'est vrai sur les coups de 23
heures
on est tombé sur sa couenne da s'appelle
arthur et acclamaient café des caleçons
qui a réussi il un peu le boulard oui
comme tout est persuadé d'être le
meilleur
sauf qu'en fait non regardez c'est nimp
arthur ne prouve qu'il a perdu et ça va
je suis la mlcc dit oui un même même le
bar et même le mercredi tout est permis
regard la belle affaire
j'ai 31 ans je suis chef de cuisine en
jordanie dans un grand hôtel
moi c'est après avoir été diplômés j'ai
atterri chez joël robuchon
c'est grâce à ça que j'ai pu passer deux
commis à chef de cuisine en deux ans et
demi ou trois ans quoi j'ai assez
confiant je suis assez excité avant de
connaître la tendance des chefs ça va
quand même nous mettre directement dans
le bain j'arrive à un point dans ma
carrière j'ai envie de me comparer aux
chefs français parce que jours et j'ai
une tournée bien sûr vers arthur et
maxime parce que vous ne ferez pas
partie de cette saison de top chef
j'ai assez conscients ou les impurs de
france et de navarre